Seit Wochen: Corona-Ausnahmesituation.
Menschen sind verunsichert,
Firmen haben keine Einnahmen,
die Regierung muss einspringen.
Wenn der Staat so viel Geld mobilisiert,
Steuergelder, dann ist es absolut legitim,
hier ein paar Kriterien aufzustellen.
Milliardenschwere DAX-Konzerne fordern
staatliche Unterstützung – wie die Lufthansa,
Deutschlands größte Airline.
Bürgerinitiativen protestieren
gegen die Rettung.
Der Vorwurf: Die Lufthansa verschiebe
gleichzeitig Gewinne in Steueroasen.
Das ist ja dann so, als wenn man dem Notarzt
bei der Rettung in die Tasche greift.
Ich frage mich, wenn wir alle,
wenn die Allgemeinheit
für große Unternehmen zahlen soll,
müsste der Staat dann nicht auch
mehr Bedingungen stellen?
Wir sind in einer veränderten Welt,
wir brauchen gemeinschaftliche Solidarität.
In der Krise zeigt er sich spendabel:
Enorme Summen fließen in alle Branchen.
Autovermieter Sixt bekommt einen
Staatskredit von bis zu 1,5 Milliarden Euro.
Elektronikhändler Ceconomy,
Mutterkonzern von Media Markt und Saturn,
kann auf rund 1,7 Milliarden zurückgreifen.
Tourismuskonzern TUI bekommt
Staatshilfen von über 1,8 Milliarden,
Sportartikelhersteller Adidas
rund drei Milliarden Euro.
Mit Abstand am meisten
geht an die Lufthansa:
neun Milliarden Euro in Form von Aktien.
Der Staat beteiligt sich
zu 20 Prozent an der Fluggesellschaft.
Sonst würde Deutschlands größte Airline
die Corona-Krise wohl nicht überleben.
Seit März ist der weltweite Reiseverkehr
um 80 Prozent eingebrochen.
Laut CEO Carsten Spohr verliert die
Lufthansa pro Stunde über eine Million Euro.
Die Teilverstaatlichung gibt der
Regierung nun ein Mitspracherecht.
Sie versichert jedoch laut Lufthansa, „die
mit den Aktien verbundenen Stimmrechte
nur in Ausnahmefällen wie dem Schutz vor
einer Übernahme auszuüben.“
Doch warum eigentlich?
Wäre eine staatliche Beteiligung nicht
eine Chance gewesen,
um zum Beispiel Auflagen
für den Klimaschutz durchzusetzen?
Ja, die Lufthansa hätte,
genau wie in Frankreich auch,
die Auflage bekommen sollen,
die Emissionen zu senken.
Wenn man schon derart hohe Mengen
an Geldern, an Finanzhilfen, an
Wirtschaftshilfen bereitstellt,
Steuergelder, dann muss auch
ein Unternehmen alles dafür tun,
dass wir die Pariser Klimaziele erfüllen.
Das ist auch eine Riesenchance
für die Unternehmen selber,
weil die Geschäftsmodelle,
die sie haben, sind nicht zukunftsfähig.
Die CO2-Emissionen zu senken, würde in
Zeiten der Klimakrise allen zugutekommen.
Der Protest richtet sich außerdem
gegen die Steuerpraktiken der Unternehmen.
Nach Recherchen der Bürgerbewegung
Finanzwende hat die Lufthansa
92 Tochtergesellschaften in
sogenannten Schattenfinanzzentren
wie Irland, der Schweiz,
Panama oder den Cayman Islands.
Auf Malta, so die Aktivisten, ist
ein Unternehmen registriert,
das mit nur zwei Beschäftigten knapp
200 Millionen Euro Gewinn macht.
Wenn der Staat wirklich auch
in einem Unternehmen dabei ist,
muss er dafür sorgen,
dass die Interessen der Steuerzahler,
also der Bürger und Bürgerinnen,
widergespiegelt werden.
Einfach dass Unternehmen,
große Unternehmen,
die jetzt Gelder erhalten oder Hilfen
erhalten,Transparenz schaffen
über ihre Unternehmensstruktur:
Wie sind sie aufgebaut?
In welchem Land zahlen sie welche Steuern?
Nur damit können wir wirklich wissen,
dass Gewinne nicht verschoben werden,
um Steuern hier zu vermeiden.
Der Staat habe die Aktien
sehr günstig bekommen,
verteidigt sich der Lufthansa-Chef:
„Theoretisch könnte der
Staat gleich nach seinem Einstieg
mit hohem Gewinn wieder aussteigen.
Das erhöht die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass der Steuerzahler eine
stolze Rendite bekommen wird.“
Es ist absolut wichtig,
dass man jetzt mit den Wirtschaftshilfen
Nachhaltigkeit und Klimaschutz fördert.
Und die Unternehmen,
die das wirklich nicht verstanden haben,
die werden sehr große Probleme bekommen.
Die werden mit der Zeit
vom Markt verschwinden.
Schon jetzt musste
die Lufthansa den DAX verlassen,
weil ihr Börsenwert in der Krise
inzwischen zu niedrig geworden ist.
Für mich ist hier eine
Chance vergeben worden.
Unternehmen stellen sich nur dann um,
wenn es sich für sie lohnt.
Wenn der Staat mit öffentlichen
Geldern Unternehmen rettet,
müssten die doch auch zum
Wohle aller agieren, oder?